très bon soir luis vous suivez
évidemment le déroulement de ces
opérations actuellement à lyon le
suspect est toujours en fuite
avez vous d'autres informations revoir
et bas qu'elle ne souhaitait pas encore
un petit quelque chose qui n'était pas
confirmée à sa mort parce qu'elle a
ajusté qui a été interpellé dans ce qui
n'est pas très loin de la fin des
suppléments se sont érodés à peine 3 km
1 dans les 3e arrondissement c3 et une
information comme quoi est cliquable
un suspect quelqu'un annonce a été a été
interpellé par la police il ya peu près
trois cent trente ou quarante minutes
dans l'anglais et entre l'avenue félix
faure et la rue baraban nous on est là
on se place
on s'est déplacés et mais on voit aucune
déploiement des polices a fait et la
formation qui n'avait su qu'il avait été
encerclée dansant dans un récent repas
dans un kebab et mais conduit à ce
moment il n'y a pas d'opération
pollution ici alma en tout cas ça je
peux vous confirmer il ya quelqu'un qui
j'ai interpellé le chef encore si c'est
le teaser au nom qui ne porterait pas
d'armes sur lui c'est ce qu'on nous
disait également pour l'instant aucune
piste n'est écartée c'est ce qu'a dit
également le maire de lyon quel est
qu'elle est comment s'est déroulée cette
agression racontez-nous ce qui s'est
passé aux alentours de 16 heures cet
après midi à lyon
oui c'était intéressant et les frais de
quelqu'un qui parle pas dans l'église en
tout cas et il venait à peine d'arriver
en france 5 en décembre
en plus des prêtres des familles les
familles et donc qu il était en train de
fermer l'église réseau nécessaire à un
individu s'est approché de lui la
tuerait reprend à deux fois deux
reprises
il ya eu en fait des confessions sur
l'armé utilisée pour cette action revu
c'est ce qu'on entend dire que c'était
des sites et des pales
mais il ya aussi une autre information
qui dit qu'ils auraient et il aurait
ouvert le feu avec un fusil de chasse
avec les canons sciés
donc voilà les compos ça après très
rapidement les voisins qui ont entendu
des formations ont prévenu les a
déstabilisés de celui ci et ce critère
l'ismans et les papiers qui sont venus
très vite être rapidement sur place
derrière jolie duchesne émerveillant il
a salué l' l'efficacité la rapidité et
de ses services et donc elles
prêteraient et évacuer les amener à
l'hôpital
et oui les intraitables à traiter avec
des décorations de slalom après le
contexte actuel joe jonas terroristes et
lui mais quel est l'état d'esprit des
lyonnais ce soir
pas très angoissée ont la plupart
contrairement à la ou les mêmes
situations donc talent en sélection et
la rue baraban je vous dis c'est
tranquille et d'ailleurs on a parlé avec
quelques personnes n'étaient même pas
arrivé mais là-bas au viième
arrondissement là où la satisfaction
oui évidemment les gens étaient très
proches angoissés et on a parlé avec des
personnes par l'émotion nous sommes dit
que tout ça commence la pandémie
maintenant tout ça et c'est qu'ils
cherchent au pied c'est que j'étais
emballée ces gens ont entendu des
détonations beaucoup d'entre eux sont
passés par des feux d'artifice sur les
pétards qui a été et j'étais quand sa
part des partenaires et non des coups de
feu et beaucoup lui en a pris déjà passé
les suites à côté et quand elle analysé
il a raison sa famille l'a prévenue et
dans notre pays pour ceux qui étaient
encore des désistements
et oui très
nous on arrête des gens plus à roissy
c'est bien de dire ça fait beaucoup mais
ça fait un cours touchent donc oui
j'entends dispose d un climat de guerre
civile
un mémo éléments qu'on a entendu et oui
évidemment les gens pour assurer qu'ils
allaient en accessoires merci beaucoup
luis carballo évidemment la piste
terroriste n'est pas encore confirmé en
tout cas toutes les pistes restent
ouvertes
on va évidemment suivre cette affaire
dans nos prochaines éditions merci luis
carballo en direct de lyon